STUDENTS WILL BE HOME FROM THEIR
FIRST DAY OF SCHOOL.
ALTHOUGH 95 PERCENT OF STUDENTS
IN THE CLARK COUNTY SCHOOL
CLASS--SOME WERE
WITHDRAWN COMPLETELY.
KATE HOUSTON IS LIVE FROM
WESTERN HIGH SCHOOL TO BREAK
DOWN THE RISE IN HOMESCHOOLING
IN OUR AREA.
((KATE HOUSTON))
YES, TODAY WESTERN HIGH
SCHOOL IS PASSING OUT
CHROMEBOOKS
TO STUDENTS AND HOLDING SOME
ATHLETIC PRACTICES.
WHILE MANY FAMILIES ARE
PREPARING TO GET BACK IN THE
CLASSROOM--SOME HAVE FILED THIS
'NOTICE OF INTENT' TO HOMESCHOOL
INSTEAD.
ONE MOM TELLS ME IT WA NECESSARY
TO MAKE SURE HER DAUGHTERS WERE
GETTING THE EDUCATION THEY
((
SARAH
MCDUFFIE/ HOMESCHOOLING KIDS:
"IT WAS REALLY SCARY AT FIRST,
JUST THE DECISION IS A HUGE
DECISION.")) ((KATE HOUSTON))
SARAH MCDUFFIE IS PREPARING TO
HOMESCHOOL HER TWO 8 YEAR OLD
SARAH
MCDUFFIE/ HOMESCHOOLING KIDS:
"THEY KIND OF GOT BEHIND LAST
YEAR, AND YOU KNOW IT'S HARD TO
TEACH IN A CRISIS.")) ((KATE
HOUSTON))
SHE ALSO WORRIES MANDATED MASKS
WILL CREATE A DIFFICULT
((
SARAH
MCDUFFIE/ HOMESCHOOLING KIDS:
"BETWEEN ALL OF THE DIFFERENT
THINGS AND JUST BEING BEHIND, WE
REALLY NEED TO BUCKLE DOWN AND
GET THE FUNDAMENTALS OF SCHOOL
PUT INTO PLACE.")) ((KATE
HOUSTON))
C-C-S-D SAYS 126 'NOTICE OF
INTENT' HOMESCHOOL FORMS HAVE
BEEN SUBMITTED FOR THE UPCOMING
YEAR.
THAT'S COMPARED TO THE NEARLY
7-THOUSAND LAST YEAR.
CHELSEA
GRAVES/COORDINATED HOMESCHOOLING
POD: "I'VE HEARD TONS OF STORIES
FROM PARENTS WHO JUST TRIED IT
OUT FOR ONE YEAR AND NOW THEY'RE
LIKE 'THIS WAS A GREAT SUCCESS
WE'LL
JUST KEEP GOING WITH IT'"))
((KATE HOUSTON))
CHELSEA GRAVES HELPED RUN A
HOMESCHOOL POD--AND IS
CONSIDERING DOING IT AGAIN THIS
YEAR.
((
CHELSEA
GRAVES/COORDINATED HOMESCHOOLING
POD: "I FEEL LIKE I WAS ABLE TO
TARGET WHERE THEY WERE, AND I
WAS ABLE TO TEACH THEM WAY MORE
EFFECTIVELY THAN I HAD EVER BEEN
ABLE TO TEACH IN A CLASSROOM OF
30 KIDS."))
((KATE HOUSTON))
GRAVES SAYS MANY CURRICULUMS ARE
EASY TO UNDERSTAND AND CAN BE
TAILORED TO THEIR CHILD'S NEEDS.
((
CHELSEA
POD "I THINK THE BENEFIT OF
BEING A PARENT IS YOU KNOW
BETTER THAN ANYONE HOW YOUR KID
IS GOING TO LEARN."))
((KATE HOUSTON))
MCDUFFIE IS NOW CONNECTING WITH
OTHER HOMESCHOOL FAMILIES TO
SHARE CURRICULUM IDEAS AND
COORDINATE WAYS TO SOCIALIZE.
((
MCDUFFIE/ HOMESCHOOLING KIDS:
"NOW I'M EXCITED WHEREAS BEFORE
I WAS SCARED AND ANTICIPATING
ALL THE WORK I WOULD HAVE TO DO
AND I JUST FEEL REALLY SUPPORTED
AND I'M EXCITED AND GLAD I
HAVE THE ABILITY TO DO THAT WITH
MY KIDS."))
((KATE HOUSTON))
C-C-S-D REQUIRES PARENTS TO
FILE A NOTICE OF INTENT AND
EDUCATIONAL PLAN, BEFORE
HOMESCHOOLING THEIR CHILD.
HOMESCHOOLED STUDENTS CAN
PARTICIAPTE IN ACTIVITIES,
SPORTS, AND UP TO THREE CLASSES
AT A SCHOOL, IF THERE IS SPACE
REQUIREMENTS.
REPORTING LIVE FROM WESTERN HIGH
SCHOOL, KATE HOUSTON, 8 NEWS
NOW.
((SALLY JARAMILLO))
<<<
PREVIOUSLY ISSUED DISCUSSION...